I wanted to start up by asking uh that
obviously Mel Brooks is such a massive
influence on film and television
particularly since the days of Sid
Caesar so for you guys what was your
first exposure to Mel Brooks whether it
was a movie or whether it was something
on television I watched history the
world up so I watched Blazing Saddles
when I was like four yeah it was a was
it Saddles was that the first one well
producers was first okay but blazing
sales I saw first yeah I'm gonna say
yeah probably Blazing Saddles for me
also yeah and it blew I mean I was even
a little kid but it's still I was like
oh my God
uh and it holds up
there's things that when you see it as a
kid you kind of don't quite understand
it but then the older you get the more
you have an appreciation for it for sure
yes definitely right but it was a short
jump from there to history the world
part one which I watched the counter
real quick 100 times
so so uh I was very uh happy when we got
the chance to work on this
I'm not gonna say your show of shows
I used to see him with the cat skills oh
yeah yeah
yeah and I I heard that this was an idea
the television show was something that
Mel had been holding on to for a while
and then brought uh Nick on and
everybody else on so can you guys uh
give me a rundown a little bit of how it
came about how you guys got involved
well Nick called me and I thought for
sure it was a prank
um I was like what uh you want me to
work with you on a Mel Brooks oh Jack a
history of the world too okay
um absolute yes 100 and then we met with
um Ike and his partner David and and it
was like absolutely yeah great match
when he called he was kind of giving me
like a cell he was like it's Eight
Episodes it's from Mel but we think we
could do some stuff and I was like just
shut up like the answer is yes you know
do you want to work with me on a Mel I
don't care who the Mel is Mel Gibson
Gourmet Bel Torme
that's it there's no Harold Melvin and
the Blue Notes that's really the last
name it doesn't count but still uh but
uh it was the world's easiest yes as far
as the sketches go obviously there's
some things in here that people have
been waiting a long time to see but in
terms of everything else because
everything else is completely new and
completely hysterical what did the kind
of the top down of building that look
like what what did you how did you
decide what was going to end up in this
project well we when we first all
started talking about what the show
could look like we kept going back to
the movie uh we knew the movie had such
a great structure where you have some of
the longer pieces where you invest a
little more time I.E Rome and French
Revolution so we knew we wanted to do
that and we you know I knew we wanted I
wanted to do a civil war thing and Wanda
wanted to tell a Shirley Chisholm story
and Nick wanted to tell a story about
you know kind of a Russian Jew living in
the shadow and so once we had those kind
of big Cornerstone uh uh worlds uh then
the then the rest of it was just a lot
of like hey what's a funny what's a
funny thing uh oh yeah Amelia Earhart uh
has opened her own bar for ladies only
um or Alexander Graham Bell right after
he made the first phone call he got the
first crank
um so it was really just yeah once we
kind of knew what those bigger pieces
were we we just had like a really fun
time for for months just what do you got
you know what I mean to give you a
period give me a funny premise give me a
character you want to play and uh then
once we kind of shot it all uh while we
were shooting and we kind of started in
our minds a little bit thinking well
this would pair up very well with this
and this goes nicely with this this
can't be with that so in post we would
have these long kind of edit sessions
where we were like this is the order of
the show and it's not going to change
and then 48 hours later we're like
totally new version with different
pieces moving around so it it was it was
uh definitely a group effort but I think
think we got it there yeah and also like
the the sketch from the movie of the you
know I give you these 15 you know ten
commandments so uh we we said let's
let's continue something from the Bible
as far as to make it a uh uh one of our
tent poles as we call them yes yeah and
was there anything because obviously
know there was a big writing team for
this so was there anything that
Cutting Room floor that you guys saw
in but then at the last minute you were
like oh no this isn't gonna work there's
so much stuff but it was not it was just
because the time right the only one we
we went down the road on writing a big
story about Cuba okay oh yeah yeah and
then by the end nothing that was shot no
no no we we ended up overwriting and
shooting the perfect amount I would say
you know
um but there are so many premises and
periods and characters that we have more
than enough for season two absolutely I
mean come on ages it writes itself
hey did you do part three yeah there you
go
yeah but was there any any characters
that YouTube played because obviously
you're in a number of the sketches not
just the sort of longer running ones was
there any that you were particular uh
particularly attached to was it Shirley
Chisholm was it Ulysses S Grant or was
it something else I'm very fond of
Shirley Chisholm and it was I've always
wanted to play Shirley Chisholm so so
getting it getting to do this and then
to do it in a format that I I love which
is multicam and I mean come on a
wardrobe alone oh my God geez so good uh
yeah but yeah that was uh that that was
just a real treat for me to be able to
uh you know to play that and have fun
and then with Marla Gibbs too oh my gosh
forget it George Wallace George Wallace
as George Wallace crazy
uh I was very into playing Lucy's S
Grant I've always said he's one of our
hottest presidents
um uh the only other character I
remember being real I mean I was excited
for a lot of them when we started
breaking the Beatles gospel I had been
watching The Beatles documentary and I
was obsessed with with Ringo and kind of
the way he talks a lot so that was a
really uh uh fun one to do uh Ringo not
one to one as uh Mark I think and one
last question for the both of you
speaking of Ulysses S Grant neither of
them are very desirable places to go to
but if you had to pick one would you
rather go to the Rock Ridge from Blazing
Saddles or the Rock Bridge from part two
you're either somewhere in the Yukon
Territory yeah in West Virginia
um
yeah yeah
um but yeah I'm gonna say that but I'm
sure there's some fun pubs in West
Virginia again you guys partied down and
you know we had a great time yeah we had
a great time it was a Party happen I'm
yeah I'll go there you say West Virginia
I'll say the original OG Rock Ridge
either way we're having a drink
well thank you guys so much it was great
to meet you great to meet you thank you